how could you multiply nine with eight
some of you have probably memorized the
multiples of nine and know the answer we
know that it is 72
but in this session we will understand
multiplication in a very different way
will this different way help us well let
me put it this way understanding this
technique will help us solve problems
like nine hundred ninety eight times
nine hundred ninety seven in about five
seconds yes without a calculator you
don't believe me do you
give me around two minutes to change
your opinion we use the concept of base
to solve multiplication problems quickly
and bases the general powers of ten like
ten 101,000 and so on when we are given
the multiplication problem the first
thing we should ask ourselves is which
base is close to both the numbers here
both numbers are close to ten so we can
say that the base is ten once the base
is decided life becomes really easy
first we subtract the base from each of
these numbers subtracting the base from
the first number we get nine minus 10
that equals minus one we write it next
to that number
next would be 8 minus ten that equals -2
these two numbers tell us how far these
two numbers are from the base 9 is minus
one units away from the base and eight
is minus two units away from the base so
the initial two steps choose the base
and subtract it from the numbers once
this is done just make a partition like
this on the Left we write the sum what
sum the sum of these two numbers or
these two numbers both will result in
the same answer either 8 plus minus 1 or
9 + - - both equals 7 so we write a 7 on
the left on the right we have the
product of these two numbers - 1 x - 2
and that equals 2 yes we should also
consider the sign when
multiplied these two numbers there you
go we have the answer
9 times 8 is 72 the steps are simple we
find the base then subtract it from each
number write the sum on the left and the
product on the right is there anything
we need to be careful about here yes on
the right the number of digits should be
equal to the number of zeros in the base
here the base has one zero so we write
just one digit on the right don't worry
everybody thinks this is difficult at
first so let's quickly solve a couple of
problems and you will see how simple
this technique actually is say we want
to multiply 98 with 97 both these
numbers as we can see are close to 100
so the base is 100 here 98-100 is -2 and
97 minus 100 is minus 3 then we make a
partition on the left we write the sum
and on the right we write the product 98
plus -3 is 95 even 97 plus minus 2 will
give us 95 and minus 2 times minus 3 is
6 so should we write a 6 here
don't forget the number of digits on the
right will be equal to the number of
zeros in the base as there are 2 zeros
and 100 there will be 2 digits here 6
will be written as 0 6 there's your
answer
98 times 97 is 9000 506 find the base
find the deviation find the sum and find
the product and we get the answer in a
few seconds
okay let's try solving a problem with
slightly bigger numbers 9996 times nine
thousand nine hundred ninety-seven why
don't you try this remember the four
simple steps find the base find the
deviation find the sum and find the
product I give you ten seconds
both numbers as we can see are close to
10,000 so the base will be 10,000 this
number is minus 4 units away and this is
minus 3 units away then we make the
partition sum on the left and the
product on the right this Plus this is
nine thousand nine hundred ninety three
the sum of these two will also give us
nine thousand nine hundred ninety three
the product will be minus 4 times minus
3 which equals twelve the number of
zeros in the base is four which means we
will have four digits on the right 12
will be written as zero zero one two
that's our answer the product of these
two numbers will equal nine nine nine
three zero zero one two wasn't this
quick faster than a calculator you think
notice that in all the examples we saw
both numbers were below the base 98 and
97 were below 100 nine thousand nine
hundred ninety six and nine thousand
nine hundred and ninety seven were below
10,000 we will look at a couple of more
examples in the next part of the session
don't forget the steps find the base
find the deviation find the sum and find
the product and we get the answer
you